i'm aware that we've had some apologies
and do you want me to record those or
have you already recorded the mallet
i have them recorded do you want me to
drop me to call the name yeah yeah
and apologies from joel mcgregor maureen
noble
councillor hines karen ahmed shawn
donolan
and caroline hemingway
and if we i think understand
yes sorry can i just add to that uh
mandy bailey and john waring from mft so
i'm here on the bar
okay thanks scott have you got those
alex yeah
i have no thank you and
if we don't do what should we do some um
introductions so that people
know who's on the call and
my name is james slater i'm the council
of restricted ward and also i'm the
second manager for health well-being
inequalities
go joe i am counselor uh johann harding
i'm a counselor that represents the ward
of urmston
and i'm the exec member for adult social
care
i'm sally johnson i'm chair of the ccg
i'm
uh part-time co-chair jain of the health
and well-being board and i'm a gp in
timpani
hello i'm john holden i'm councillor for
saint mary's
hello i'm dorothy evans i am the ceo for
the african caribbean care group and vce
and c rep for
the health and wellbeing board thank you
hi i'm eleanor roethlin director of
public health
how about your honor
how did you yeah i'm heather fairfield
and i'm the chair of
healthwatch trafford
i don't know what order you're going in
goldbridge
it's hard when you collect it so i'm i'm
councillor jane brophy and i
represent timberly ward and i'm here on
behalf of my group
and just to repeat it's scott logan from
mft and what with
mandeville and john murray
martin pritchard accountable officer nhs
trafford
linda uh i'm council linda blackburn i'm
shadow exec member for health well-being
and equalities
hi i'm tom maloney i'm program director
for the council and the ccg
i'm here for one of the items today to
give an update on the
locality stroke recovery plan
i'm mark jarvis i'm medical director at
trafford ccg
we have somebody on the phone
hi and that might be me um i'm alice
seaborn i'm the medical director at gmmh
i'm really
sorry i can't get on zoom because our
security's so tight here
so i'm on the phone rather than being
able to see people
thanks sally is that everybody
thank you and if people have um
comments around any of the papers that
have been presented can they put those
in the chat well obviously if you want
to ask a question
and can you raise your hand and then
i'll bring you in and
just so that we can we can record
comments in in the chat easier
and so if we move on we've got two sets
of minutes
it's the minutes of the 20th of february
and also
um the 15th of may so and we agree those
as a correct record
are there any declarations of interest
from
um anybody today
i mean i just want to declare that i
work for cancer research uk
and sometimes those items come up on the
agenda so i think it's worth noting
thanks thank you nobody else
okay yeah i i think i should declare an
interest i work for the nhs
but outside of greater manchester in
blackburn
okay thanks jane and
i haven't been notified of any urgent
business so if we um
move on to um questions from a member of
the members of the public alex i haven't
i'm not aware of any
alex any questions from members of the
public we've not received any
all right thank you all right then if we
can move on to item six
and it's the outbreak management plan
and
um over to you elena please
hi everyone so it's a very
interconnected agenda today
um what i'm suggesting is i'll give you
a quick overview of the outbreak
management plan
then i'll talk to you about um how we're
implementing
the work of the outbreak rate management
plan and particularly the work
of the public engagement board and the
health protection board
both which are on the agenda um
and um particularly then the ten point
action plan
that we've got in place to um to
progress this work
but between talking about the outbreak
management plan
at some point would you like a little
overview of where we're up to at the
moment
as well so i'll do that as well i don't
know whether to start with us or finish
with that
um i think let's start with the outbreak
management plan because it feels like
that's a piece
this um we had we were asked um at the
beginning of june
produced an outbreak every area of the
every um upper
local authority had to produce an
outbreak management plan
which we finished and published and it's
been on the council website
since the start of july it feels i'm
just looking at it today
and it feels like a long time ago that
we wrote it and it feels as well that
we've been giving it a really good
testing
over the last month um so the outbreak
management plan
is it's a working document
and it sends out our um
how we're responding to covid and it's
separated into two
parts on in our plan what we've
separated into the things that we're
doing to prevent
outbreaks and to reduce the risk of
spread the things we're doing to respond
to outbreaks breaks authorizing levels
of infection
but within the prevent element um we
have a section
on the infection prevention and control
that we're doing
um the so uh what how we're supporting
people with personal protective
equipment but also
some of the messaging and so on about
social distancing hand washing and etc
we have a section on communications and
engagement which is really important
because this
this is increasingly evident that this
is going to be something that we are
only going to be able to manage
with really the full cooperation and
engagement of with our local population
um and really supporting them to engage
with the steps that people will need to
take
to reduce the risk of infection we have
a section in it on
our testing program and i can take um
and we have i'll um we have
uh two three possibilities for testing
in trafford you can either
well four testing via a hospital system
testing via um the static sites
at the etihad stadium and at manchester
airport
i'm testing custom via our mobile
testing units
which um move around as you can get from
the title
and we usually have either at um
sail water park or at the ua 92
or another trafford house also in
stratford
i'm sorry there are five testing options
we also have a local testing service
um which we are implementing our testing
service in passington in september
and in trafford park shortly and i'll
talk a little bit more about those
um and finally of course people can get
tests
online so one of the big pieces of work
is just making sure everybody
understands where they can get the tests
and how to access that and when they
need those tests
but we have really good access now to
testing within traffic
the next section of the plan looks at
the contact tracing so what happens when
somebody gets a positive test result
what needs to be done how do we identify
the contacts and how do we get the
messages through to those contacts that
they need to self-isolate
i think one of the issues we've had has
been
that the messaging around testing and
contact tracing i think has got a little
bit confused
and a lot of people think if they get a
negative test result
they don't need to self-isolate but if
they are a contact of a case if they've
been to if they
if they're getting a test because
they're contacting the case
and they've chosen to get a test even if
they have no symptoms
even if they have a negative test result
they still have to come they still have
to self-isolate
for those 14 days and i think one of the
pieces of work i think we'll be needing
to pick up is how we get that message
out more clearly to people
um the next section the plan looks at
the closing engagement yeah becomes an
engagement obviously
then within the contact racing we're
also looking in the prevention world
we're also looking at where are our high
risk settings so where are the settings
that we
think is either more likely to have
spread
of good disease or if you did get a case
in one of those settings the
consequences would be more
more dangerous so obvious examples of a
place where the consequences would be
more serious
are care homes um it is where
the risk might be higher or the um
communications etc
where the risk may not be as high but
the communications and the um
the management of the case would be more
difficult for obviously places like
schools
some workplaces so people will have
heard a loss about process
food um and risks within some of those
settings
we've we've identified a very long list
of high risk
settings in trafford and again um we can
and particularly the implications of
places like trafford park and the number
of employees
has been something that's that's really
we've become very aware of
over the last month um and the final
section the plan looks at all the data
that we get and the surveillance and the
analysis that we've been doing
and so that's the prevent side and then
the other side of the plan
looks at our response um so how do we
manage an outbreak how do we identify an
outbreak
what do we do um when there is an
outbreak um
and that is the bread and butter to be
honest of public health
um i feel i've said a lot
um does anyone have any questions about
any of that
yeah and counselor brophy would like to
come in mark i've noted your comments in
the chat
i just for some reason it's not letting
me respond in the chat so
and i've no i've noted that but yeah
jane i've noted you're quite
you want to ask a question so come on in
that i've unmuted um yeah thank you for
the report
i'm just uh looking at page 13
um because i'm kind of looking in from
the outside really i'm not
part of the group of people that is
looking day by day at all the data
but what what was clear to me when
trafford was on the news
um that actually the way we had the high
incidence in trafford for a while i
wasn't
down to any of those particular groups
that were identified on page 13.
so i was wondering if we could have some
thoughts about
what have we learned from that because
the plan looked at all those potential
areas where we would have spread any
care homes yes of course they had
some terrible incidences and quite high
incidences
but the spread in trafford seemed to be
young people going out to pubs when
the lockdown was lifted and then they
brought the
infection home to to parents i wondered
if
eleanor's got some comments on on how
that actually happened and what we could
learn from that scenario
yeah no absolutely and it's one of those
things where you
you do a lot of planning in advance um
and you think of all the things that you
can think of beforehand
and then reality hits you and it's it's
something quite different
and i think i think it took i think
certainly it took me by surprise what
happened in trafford
um and because the narrative up to then
and the national narrative was quite a
different story
so we'd obviously by the time of um
lockdown ending
we had seen what was happening in
leicester
and so a lot of us have been doing an
awful lot of work we'd seen what had
happened in kirkleese they had a big
outbreak in a
food processing factory obviously all
the way through early on
all through february and march we were
really working to protect her
and april we were really working in
traffic to protect our care homes
because we knew of the risk there and um
so it was only when i started i mean
because the data the way the data has
come through has been
quite it was quite slow for us to get
the
detail of anything more than just
numbers
and it was literally that that spike
that we got in those 17 to 22 year olds
was literally the week that i got the
access to the data so that i was able to
see that
data if it had happened the week before
i would not have had any idea of what
was causing it
so i think it probably i think what we
what i've learned from that is that i
think there is
um still generalized community
transmission in trafford
at you know it's not at the level of um
transmission the level of
disease in the population now is nowhere
near the level it was
in march and april so i don't want
anyone to think that we're at the rates
that we're at in march in april but nor
do i want anyone to think that we
couldn't get back to those rates
so i think i just thought what happened
was that we saw people mixing more
that that level of infection that have
been bubbling along
probably at that low level not
causing huge disease anywhere
managed to you know that when people
started mixing more in
in july and particularly you know young
people in fact they've had a
terrible time this summer i mean really
dreadful that that group you know that
those 17 and 18 year old sisters meant
to be their summer isn't it the 18 year
olds have finished their exams
they've got that time off before they go
to university in a lot of places
and you know you can absolutely
understand they wanted to party
um so i suspect as well and this is my
personal theory
not backed up by anything other than
personal view is that i think as well
the weather we had in july was
absolutely shocking
it's hard to remember now when it's so
hot but it was it rained more or less
incessantly and so i suspect that people
who had been meeting up
outdoors started meeting up indoors the
pubs were open again
so you could go there and
you know the risk of transmission
outdoors is much higher indoors
indoors is much higher than outdoors so
i suspect
it was that and then i suspect that what
they did was incredibly responsibly
when somebody became ill and went off
and to get a test
they i think they went on instagram and
they went from snapchat and they
told all their friends because by the
time we picked it up by the time i
picked it up
and we started doing that publicity
about it over that following weekend i
picked it up on the sort of
tuesday wednesday we got a lot of
publicity out
really early on that friday and the gp
sent out messaging
on on friday and saturday um
which i'd say and we put lots of stuff
on council websites which
to be fair was aimed more at parents
than the children than the young people
um just because of who who we suspect
looks at those websites
by the time we got to that point they'd
stopped going for the test so i think
we've got that cohort
we are now seeing we have been starting
to see some of their parents coming
through not in huge numbers
but i think it was that we we have just
had
more community transmission more
confidence in a lot of our communities
about going out
and and that has led to more spread in
the population that perhaps
because of the messaging that had been
going on in leicester
about game populations about deprivation
and so on
meant there's a lot of people in
trafford maybe didn't think that that
messaging applied that the risk was real
for them
and i think one of the big things we
have to keep reiterating is
what kovid likes is humans
and the easiest way to spread it is by
human to human and by that contact and
it really doesn't mind
anything else other than whether you're
a human
thank you elena does anybody else have
any questions
no okay thank you thanks for all the
hard work in that in that report and in
your presentation
i know that if we hadn't got public
health got alone knows where we would be
at the minute so thank you so much for
joining the team and it's over to you
again
what can i put my hand give them give
them the words any other questions can i
just briefly ask eleanor to follow up
um because again as i said i'm not
somebody who's got access to the data
right now
has that situation with the young people
been brought under control
or is trafford still looking at further
measures there
so what we're seeing now is actually
quite a change in our demographics so
we're not seeing that peak in that
youngest age group
we're but 90 of the cases we're getting
so i'll just give you a little bit of an
update on where we're up to at the
moment because i think that will
will probably help we had as you know we
had very high rates for a week or
two at the end of july our rates started
to go up around about the 17th of july
um they are now dropping
but i use that with some caution because
on monday this week
we had the highest number of cases that
we've had since the 27th of july
um so we were number four in the country
at one point we're now about number 27
so even though we're seeing a crew
in improvement we are a long way away
from where we want to be and we're a lot
higher than we were
at the beginning of july our rates so we
have we've had 61 cases in the week
between the 4th the 10th of august
um that gives us a rate of about 25 per
hundred thousand
um now 90 percent of those cases were in
our working age population so that's the
18 to 65 year olds
week most over half of them were in the
35 to 65 year olds
this week over half of them are in the
18 to 34 year old so it's
it's a bit of a moveable feast um but
we're seeing some areas of seeing more
women the men testing positive we're
seeing slightly more men than women
which again is quite interesting because
um
we tend to think that women are more
likely to go for any sort of health care
testing and so on but we are seeing more
men than women and slightly more
um in terms of ethnicity um it more or
less mirrors the ethnicity within the
borough
um we were seeing more cases
proportionately
in more cases in white
population um particularly when we were
seeing the most cases in the south of
the borough
now we're seeing more cases in the north
of the borough we're seeing an increase
in the
asian population and testing positive
but we're still on about
two-thirds white 20
asian in the latest data set which
um and again as your the younger
you the younger the people who are being
tested the more likely you are to have a
diverse ethnic mix obviously because we
have quite different populations where
we're
where we're really um pleased at the
moment um
and we are working very hard to maintain
this is that we are
fortunately not seeing very many cases
at all in our
over 65 population and particularly not
in our care homes but this is something
that we are working extremely hard
to maintain because keeping keeping home
care and
um care homes free from coded
19 is one of our main priorities and
you know again huge learning from
obviously what happened in in
in march and april so that's that's the
that's our latest figures and our latest
demographics
um but i i would say that what we have
in
in trafford is not the picture that you
see nationally
we are not seeing this in huge we're not
seeing lots of
cases in single households we're not
seeing lots of multi-generational spread
at the moment in trafford but my concern
is that
um as i say kovid likes humans and covid
likes humans that
live and work close to each other and if
you're
in those conditions it makes it very
much more difficult to stop that spread
thank you and council harding do you
want to come in with your question
yeah thanks and thanks counselors later
so
i guess if two um two points eleanor um
i think the communications and the way
we get the messaging out is absolutely
critical the point you made about young
people
is absolutely right um i have a 16 year
old myself who's been
impacted by this we have to strike a
balance between well-being
than having social contact because you
know the social anxiety around young
people now they've not been able to
to sort of get on with their lives so
the messaging we have to get out there
isn't about demonizing it's about
messages that you know trying to keep
people safe
we've got young people accessing exam
results
we've just had a level results we've got
gcse results coming out next week and
historically young people like to
gather and celebrate their exam results
so i'm just wondering what messaging we
might be considering getting out over
the next couple of days
that's still encouraging young people to
um the things they can do as opposed to
the things
they can't do um and what you've said
about protecting the over 65s is
absolutely right i'm not keen on the
don't kill granny
message from um from oldham however
how do we get that in a way that it's
still about whatever you do may impact
on older people and certainly the work
of the age world board
will be we'll be taking some of that
forward so so my question
what comes are we going to do about
younger people
if they're getting exam results and
they're looking to celebrate
the second question i have is around
data
are we getting the right data that we
need
because i know that it's been mentioned
you don't have to
declare your employment or ethnicity
and this can have a significant impact
on how we manage
outbreaks in our communities is there
anything we can do
to influence lobby or shape how we might
get this data thank you and i'll start
with the young people and the
celebrations and so on and i think
i mean it's inevitable they're going to
be out they're going to be celebrating i
think the messages i would be giving is
um please celebrate outdoors if you can
try and remember to keep that social
distancing remember that you could be
asymptomatic
and that young people are much more
likely to be asymptomatic
or have very low levels of symptoms so
take it seriously do go for a test if
you have any concerns and if you feel
you're sympathetic
if you have been in a big group and
especially if you've been in a big group
where you've you know where people have
been drinking where people have perhaps
been a bit disinhibited
and if it's been indoors if you have
really now is not the time to go and
visit your grandparents
if you're not living with them um
you might you know stay if you want if
you don't
please don't go and visit them now and
obviously we've got the
we've got the local lockdown as well so
it really is you know
give it give it a week keep
keep yourself away from high risk from
high risk people
highly vulnerable people if you if you
feel that you might have put yourself at
risk
don't put anyone else at risk from that
so i think that's that's probably the
one of the messages and just be very
aware of what the symptoms are
if one of your friends goes down with it
you know if you're a contact
self-isolate for those 14 days
take a test if you're worried about it
but even if you're if it's negative if
you're a contact you must self-isolate
so it really is you know absolutely have
fun have
try and have as normal a life as
possible but
think about people who may be more
vulnerable than you are
and how you protect them we've got a
meeting in fact helen
and um uh kate murdoch and our team
are currently meeting with traffic
council with traffic college
about the return to college and so on so
we're working and we're
working really closely with the schools
and with karen samples and her team
to make sure that schools can get
messaging out and similarly our youth
services have been work doing a lot of
work
all summer including on developing
materials with young people
because obviously anything i say is
highly unlikely to be
of any credibility to anyone so there
has been messaging and videos and so on
being designed by our young people for
use with young people
and i think that's something that we
probably one of the pieces of work
i think is quite urgent for us to do in
trafford
um and i'll talk a little bit about our
10-point plan but
um is really making sure we've got the
comms for all their different population
groups
and that we get those out maybe use more
more videos and more clips and so on on
our website and make more use of that
and how we how we get those messages out
to people
and the point around um lobbying council
harding we had we did
actually have a meeting and i think it
was wednesday with the
uh covid19 task force um
and we raised at that meeting and
those issues around you know tracking
and tracing you know
people we do need to have employment
details in that
in that data so that if actually there's
an outbreak in a
specific business or um you know
hospital or something like that we need
we need to know how we then
sort of like manage that so those those
were the things that
were addressed and i think the task
force said they would take that back to
westminster for arizona didn't they so
i think it was quite positive that we
said that that information about
employment needed to be part of the
track and trace information
okay absolutely the um the employment we
want to make sure that that's included
in the contact tracing
data the ethnicity is normally
self-recorded by the people by people at
the point that they booked the test so i
think one of the issues there is making
sure that people
that we normalize asking the questions
about ethnicity and i know
martin um richard and mark will be very
bored of me
romain and sally will be very bored of
me reminding gps
of the importance of making sure that
our gp records are up to date
with ethnicity recording i think you
know the world of ethnicity
covid has been um so significant
and so well publicized i really do think
we it's absolutely time that we really
push
hard to make sure that that ethnicity
that people are really
strongly encouraged to record their
ethnicity and to understand why that
question is being asked
um we're not i mean to in traffic to be
fair on the data we're getting
it's about 90 of the people have
recorded their ethnicity
so you know it's clearly the majority of
people are
are perfectly willing to to to record
that than that fantastic
um so i think it is about just making
sure that that is
at every opportunity it is pushed that
we do need that data
and martin do you want to come in it
counts for blackburn i have seen your
hand so i'll bring you in after martin
thank you
thanks jamie it's to um respond to joe's
point about data if this is not a
political
point but i think one of the things that
would help is
um showing up the the welfare systems
uh in a way that means that people don't
feel that they'll be penalized if they
say
where they work and like you um i also
met the kovic task force
made the same point which is um if if
people feel like they wouldn't be
financially penalized for
um not going into work then that would
really help people i think give the data
freely about where they're working their
employment so in terms of
lobbying um which is more your role as
politicians than mine
um i think that point will be really
helpful to be consistently made
martin that was that was something that
we did talk about and we
talked about funding going forward if we
have a second wave in the autumn so
those those things are really really
important and council blackburn do you
want to come in
thank you could i just ask elena and to
comment on the numbers
of the residents who have been
hospitalized and
also that you know the numbers of people
who have been discharged
so at the moment in this latest wave um
or this latest number
numbers increasing we haven't seen a big
increase in hospitalization at all at
the moment which is really good news
but in part i think that's because of
the characteristics of people who've
been found to be positive
so when you are the younger age group
are much less likely to need hospital
treatment
um also there's a usually quite a delay
between
becoming ill with covid and needing
hospital treatment so
usually eight at eight days minimum um
to two weeks
so again we wouldn't expect to see an
immediate
um link between a test result coming
back positive and immediate levels of
hospitalizations going up
but at the moment fortunately we're not
seeing an increase
in the hospitalizations um as far as
um we went last time i looked which was
about two days ago
scott can probably comment more on that
um and equally on the discharges
could i just ask then do you think that
the most vulnerable
are keeping safe then i suspect that
definitely that i think we've probably
got um in many things
and as in many things in uh our country
we probably have
to quite a divided population and i
think we have some people who have
who are incredibly anxious and really
you know have potentially too anxious
even
and and it's having a poor impact on
both our mental and physical health
and then we've got another group of the
population who are really quite blase
and it's really trying to get that
healthy balance between
treating covid with respect and not
allowing it to destroy your life
um so how how we manage to get that
balance
as a as a society i think is one of the
how we manage to live
with the threat of covid um
and and appropriately protect our most
vulnerable people
but not get people so terrified that
actually by you know because really
we do not want people staying inside all
all the time you know people do need to
be out and about people do need to
socialize with other people we are
we are social animals um so it's really
trying to get that balance but i do
think
i think to an extent some people are
potentially
um feeling that they have to stay in and
away from people because they're worried
about other people's behavior
and i think that's sometimes how we see
you know and that is sometimes i think
showing in
in some of the hostility that you get
and for example some of the
you know reports in about neighbours
doing x y and z and so on
okay thank you and
diane's got a comment in the chat i know
that you raised your hand diane do you
want to just come in so that we can have
it recorded
what the information and then we'll move
on to the next um item
thank you yes thank you jane uh it's
just to answer the question of the
number of discharges
of counsellor blackburn we've made 960
discharges since the 19th of march where
we supported
960 discharges um up till last monday
which is double what we would normally
do in the same period just so that their
members are aware
thank you diane and if we can move on
then to item seven it's the health
protection board
action plan and over to you please hello
um so i think maybe so
you've got in your papers the health
protection board action plan and the
public engagement board action plan and
i'm just going to say a little bit about
both boards and then i'm going to
put up for you to see our 10-point plan
because i think that makes sense of the
actions that we're taking
so we have two boards that we've
established as part of the outbreak
management plan
um and these were boards that we were
asked to um
the statutory um requirement to
establish these boards
we one of them is the health protection
board and that reports
up through the into the gold command so
as part of the local resilience forum
um structures to management of a major
incident
and the health protection board is
broadly speaking internal facing
it's the council and the ccg in the main
and
it is looking at all the things that we
need to do as
officers and as as public sector in um
organizations to manage the risks and
reduce the risk from coving
but that very much picking up all of the
the work that we need to be doing to
make sure that our testing systems are
robust that we have the
plans in place for the contact rating
that we
have um sufficient ppe and that we're
getting that to the right people at the
right time
and that we're understanding and doing
that analysis of the data that's coming
through so that we're really
understanding what's happening as much
as we can in the borough
so that we can act quickly to respond to
it
so that is the health protection board
the other side of that is doing the same
work but
an external facing is the cons is the
public engagement board and that is very
much about the communication and
engagement that we have to have
and that we have to demonstrate and
deliver with our population so the
the public engagement board is the
outward facing board
and it's really the board where we need
to hear from people
about what they understand what would
help them keep
safe how do we get those messages out to
people how do we get messages out to
people
in a way that makes sense to them um
and how do we hear from people what's
difficult for them so for example the
point that martin was just making
about um the if you're on a low income
and you're asked to self-isolate
um but you can't afford not to work what
do we do
how do we support that what you know we
can link into obviously the food banks
the community hubs and so on
we don't have funding to give direct
money to those that group of people
which is what they need
um but it is about how we understand how
we can work with employers
and with um with our population to
really
make co trafford and our traffic people
as covered safe cover secure as we
possibly can
and as i was saying before that's mainly
going to be coming from
how we support all of us how our
businesses work how we work how we live
and that's those are the changes we need
to make and that is the work of our
public engagement board
and i'm going to try and share my screen
um because what we've developed
um is
a 10-point action plan we are
aiming to which i can't even
find on here now yeah is that
can you see that
let me try again
and share screen
can you see that no no
um
i can give it a try if you'd like okay
let me forward you this
alex because i'm not sure if you've got
it um
okay
if any while i try and do this send this
to alex
um
alex it's the penultimate slide in the
thing i've just sent you
okay
okay all right it's because it's a slide
i don't know if anyone has any questions
on the public engagement board or the um
health protection board public
engagement board reports directly into
this board
so this is the overview board for public
engagement
question councillor brophy yeah so
i've had a look at the structure of them
from the things that are circulated with
the agenda
are these um new structures or are they
just
adaptions of existing structures and
are they kind of coming about in the
form they are because of covid or is
this a development that was happening
anyway
so the um sorry oh yeah
at the we have an exit these are really
additional boards that are going into
existing structures
so we've tried as much as possible to
make sure that we only use systems that
we already have in place because that's
much more sustainable
so but they are two new boards because
of the need to have this particular
focus around covid at the moment
but they i think i think one of the
things with them is that
we're getting a lot of learning
especially with the public engagement
board
and the one before the slide before that
one brilliant thank you
um we it will give us if we can get the
public engagement board to work well
for covet it'll also work well for any
other sort of service design we want to
do because it is actually about getting
that public voice
into our service planning and that's the
goal and that's a goal we've been
speaking about
at length in this board and in all sorts
of other boards and with the local care
alliance and i know tom will be speaking
about that shortly
so this is our 10-point plan for august
to september what we're trying to do is
make sure that we have
actually really clear actions that we're
putting in place over the next six weeks
it will
be a rolling program so some of the
things we'll we'll add to
will achieve but this is to get make
sure that we're really focusing our
attention on the things that we need to
happen
so there's a lot of actions underneath
each of these but what we've got here is
um
a 10-point plan because these are the
things these are the
high-level aspects and then the details
in um actions underpinning these
that we think will make the difference
to um
to our outbreaks and to the management
code in in stafford
the one is about how we use our data and
intelligence to underpin our decision
making
how we increase the access to an uptake
of
testing and one of the things we're
really keen on making sure that we're
actually getting the testing
for the people at the highest risk that
we are focusing our testing it was not
just the scattergun approach
but we are focusing our testing on
people that we think are at highest risk
of having covered 19.
we are working on pc on our contact
racing working very much with our
environmental health
colleagues about the capacity to respond
to local outbreaks
we have had a number of local outbreaks
within businesses
um the work we've been talking about
about the community engagement plans for
targeted areas
and also with specific groups that
amplification of the
key communication messages and the role
of all of us on the board
in developing and spreading those
messages
the work with the hospitality sector and
with businesses to make sure that they
can work
safely and effectively because
clearly covid is a public health
emergency has enormous health
implications but
we have to be careful that the reaction
to it doesn't lead to such economic
shock
that we have a whole load of other
adverse health consequences arising from
that
and that's the real balance isn't it
with us for all of us
in how we manage this how do we manage
this as safely as possible
keep people well without leading to a
whole load of other
consequences that actually have enormous
implications for people's health and
well-being as well
including unemployment so um the big
piece of work on how we keep employment
and
uh safe and the hospitality sector
the work that we're going to be doing
and that we're continuing to do on
people who are clinically vulnerable
and to support people who need to be
shielded
um and that's something that um diane
and her team and others have done an
enormous amount of work on
then we've got the infection control
making sure that everybody is
embedding good infection control
practice across all of our sectors
um including how people understand the
advice from public health england
and how to use personal protective
equipment
big piece of work as you can imagine on
the return of schools
um and colleges in september and
absolutely
critical that we get our children and
young people back into school
and into college and then finally the
piece of work about
if if things happen if things go
out of control or if things look as if
they're heading to the wrong direction
what are the actions that we will take
that will address
these the issues that we are seeing in
trafford so making sure that whatever we
do
is proportionate and is likely to be
effective
um to our local situation remembering
that we are
not the same as every other barrier in
trafford and where we see outbreaks may
be different and may be the same
so how are we making sure that we're
responding appropriately to those
to those um to any issues as they arise
and that we're really effective
in in delivering effective and
proportionate
so that is the plan
and the work of the boards
thank you eleanor and councillor brophy
i see that you want to ask a question if
anybody else has got any questions can
you put your hands up please thank you
so my question to eleanor thank you for
the 10 point plan
is around the point near the end about
schools and colleges
and because we're hearing from national
government that if we are going to get
schools and colleges open safely and we
control the transmission within those
environments
that there might have to be compromises
elsewhere so in your
public health opinion as regards to
trafford where do you think the
compromises might have to be elsewhere
in terms of public
restrictions
sorry um i think at the moment we're
still working through
what we've what we've seen with schools
in
in the because schools have been open
all the way through this and we've been
working really closely with schools and
i think the schools and the head
teachers
um have become much more confident in
how they manage day to day
in these circumstances and obviously
particularly secondary schools
um the risks are potentially higher i
think in primary schools
the risk of transmission between and
from younger children does seem to be
quite low and the impact of the disease
is much less in in that age group
so i think there is something about how
all of us will need to behave as adults
in order to reduce the risk of
transmission because what we've seen
in a lot of the outbreaks we've had is
that the workplace has done really good
work for managing the risk
in the working environment
but where they've been increased risks
have been in some of the
if you like peripheral activities that
aren't exact that so the canteens
or the smoking shelters or the travel to
and from work
in short car sharing or the um
or the fact that colleagues meet at work
and go for a drink afterwards
so it's actually about how we manage all
of our behavior
but we have to be thinking about covid
not only when we're in the workplace but
also when we're not in the workplace
so i think the school the the main thing
that we can do to keep
schools safe is twofold one is
um to make sure that every child who
goes to school is well
that you don't do that thing that i'm
sure many of us as parents have done
which is you know
you'll feel much better when you get
there on you go
um that we can't be doing that if your
child's got a bit of a cough and a cold
they do not go to school and that's
that's really different messaging isn't
it
um than we've had before so i think it's
make sure if child is not well they
don't go to school
ditto with colleagues no heroics about
going in with your streaming cold and
giving it to everybody it could be
copied
you know if you're coughing if you're
not well you stay off
now that's quite you know we we're not
used to that are we we've got a real
culture of
soldiering on so i think we'll have to
those two pieces of behavior will have
to change
and i think we will have to think about
um
how do we make sure that we protect
other people in our families and
and some of this comes back to martin's
point about
the the the consequences um of not
of being on a low income at this time if
you're in a big enough house
that you can keep different family
members well segregated from each other
you've got much less risk of that
transmission but if you're in a job
where you have a lot of face-to-face
contact particularly for delivering
personal care
and you then and you're living in an
overcrowded house
it makes it very difficult for you to
actually protect either yourself or
others so i think it is for all of us
to be kind to each other to recognize
illness
not to go into school if people are
unwell and
the other thing is that because of all
the work that's been done
we do know how to react quickly so we've
got those bubbles we can do those
contact tracing we can understand
what who needs to be off if somebody
becomes positive what does that mean for
the other people that they might have
contacts with
what does it mean to be a contact and i
think in secondary schools in particular
they're going to be
you know they've already got really good
at working out who a contact is who
and who isn't a contact and so i think
it is about that
that we're in a much better place
because of the speed of the response
so at the moment i'm hoping that if we
can
all really work together and think covid
we won't need to have big reactions of
closing other things down
but if we can't then i suppose i would
be saying well we need to think about
the things
what are the things that are essential
to society and education is one of them
and there are other things that are less
essential um
and we have to you know maybe compromise
particularly over the winter
thank you and council harding do you
want to come in
yeah i think the point that you've just
raised and eleanor about
um changing the culture instead of just
soldiering on that if you become well
you don't
go to work etc my concern around this is
is about poverty really
um for people that don't really have a
choice
or feel they don't have a choice because
it's the matter of putting food on the
table or keeping a reef over the head
because
there's some they're simply not paid
sometimes if they don't go into work
so um i wonder what our approach is as a
council in making sure that we
we know we've got the hubs that provide
the humanitarian crisis response so i
think we still need to be having a bit
of a push
when the schools and colleges go back to
make sure the traffic assist message is
out there
citizen's advice because frankly some of
us who are in a lucky position that can
work from home
if we needed to do that
there are many people that can't and
those people are very often in the low
paid jobs
but if they don't go in you know the
retail and hospitality sector
um really and they are impacted
by this disease anyway so i'd like us to
think about what our response is from a
poverty
point of view and what what we can do to
support people
a bit better because you're right that
message has to be there but we've got to
balance that
absolutely and i i mean i think you've
all heard me on numerous occasions i'm
sure
i've bored everybody on this board and
elsewhere poverty kills
inequality kills and that's what we've
seen with covert
and it's shown such a light on where we
are
as a society i feel on that
you know on that systematic and
particularly around some of the bam
issues
around our marmot's been tweeting
repeatedly about structural racism
and that has you know we have to be open
about the fact that this has happened
and we can't blame
people you know i am really concerned
that some of the narrative around
um the covered issues in in oldham or in
blackburn
have sounded like victim blaming to me
and i
you know this is not about like we have
this is a different thing that we have
to live with i'm not interested in
blaming anyone
who gets it you know whether young
people are partying of course young
people are partying
of course they are you know but let's
let's
let's think about how we support people
um rather than and and and how and what
that means
what poverty means in this situation and
for some of our schools and some of
you know in some areas what we've seen
is in in our more affluent areas parents
have been
desperate to get their children back
into school um
in some of our more deprived areas we've
had populations have been frankly
terrified
about getting their children back to
school so again that
inequality gap increasing because if we
don't get those children
from the more deprived areas back into
school that gap will continue to grow
so it really is about how we support
people and how we get a message out
that actually i think schools are safe
and i would not be saying that if i
didn't think that
i think we can make school safe and i
think we have to make schools safe
thank you and heather do you want to
come in
uh yeah just please a couple of um
issues
one is that we've raised over several
months the issues of
uh welfare rights and the fact that
people do not claim what they're
entitled to
and you know i recognize the comments
about um
cabs and so on but their hours
and the days of the week that the is so
restricted that
what you're not able to do is to be able
to adequately
um reflect that and i do wonder whether
the council could
do something in a very practical sense
about
um you know allowing people to be able
to come in and have some
conversations about what their welfare
rights are because we know that
nationally
um you know thousands and thousands of
people do not claim what they're
entitled to
and i do think that that should be part
of any poverty
strategy the second point i just wanted
to make about
uh general um getting feedback from the
public
is that our um our survey went out
a few weeks ago and what we're aiming to
do
is not to wait till the end of september
to come back with the results we're
hoping that we can come back
with an interim report uh probably some
time
uh this next week and we have had
lots and lots of comments um from
members of the public you know if you
give somebody a box then they're
gonna fill it in with the stories and
and these might take a little bit longer
uh to analyze uh we've had a couple of
hundred so far
uh but we will be doing that work and we
will feed into the
public engagement board about what the
key themes are that are coming back
directly from the public
and i would encourage anybody on this
call if they haven't filled in
the survey or sent it to colleagues if
they would
please do so and and you can pick it up
on the healthwatch
um trafford website thanks
but if diane wants to respond to the
welfare rights
question and we we do have a welfare
rights service a number of
um acts support access to support for
welfare rights
and so i i think it's a really good
point obviously um the poverty strategy
doesn't need to include
how we support people at the the points
during the coveted work as their
finances start to change significantly
as well
and we are doing a piece of work across
all of our services to look at what that
might
um look like for the future and i think
the point
about opening times is really important
and access points so i'll take that on
board head there and
include that in some of the scope of the
work thanks john
thank you diane um if nobody's got any
further questions and we can move on
then you've talked seven and eight there
together so if we can move on to
um item nine it's the lca distant board
i think that's you tom
it is yes diane did you want to do a
little bit of an introduction before i
go into the
slides yeah just give you time to get
the slides on tom
okay that's all right um there's been a
considerable amount of work we brought
in an update last time this is the uh
further reflection on that so it sets
out the priorities of the work
um around the programme bringing forward
the locality plan
uh work and reflecting on all of the
covid activity
um and the phase three letter that has
now been received with the full details
of what's required for the winter
planning
and all of our partners priorities so
you can imagine the size of the the work
that sits behind this
that tom is leading on our joint behalf
and
it isn't just about those nhs priorities
in the way three letter though so we do
need to stress this is about making sure
that the longer term planning that we
are doing
links the current needs into what is
right for our residents
uh going forward and comments and like
heather's reflection then
are really important in in how we make
sure that this works for all of our
residents and doesn't leave anybody out
obviously pace is really important
because we've learnt a lot through the
covid work that we can work at speed we
can work in a very different way
obviously some of the legislation has
changed whether that will continue
at this stage we're unclear so we are
working with a
a number of um
uncertainties as we move forward but we
are working really collectively
and so hopefully the presentation will
give you a sort of overview of the
work to date thank you and hopefully
over to tom
thanks diane um are we able to share the
screen with the presentation
you should be able to if you click on
the screen button at the bottom of the
bar
in the middle of your screen it says
sorry it does say that i need to install
a chrome extension
um which obviously i uh won't have the
ability to do this second
problem i have access to your uh
presentation so i'll just put it up and
just give me one second um
i'll start and then we can just sort of
wait through some of the slides
and enter into a more general discussion
and some reflections
um so i suppose building on diane's
comments um
i think it's it's good to set the
context of uh over the previous
um oh well over the course of 2019
particularly from sort of may onwards
thank you very much if we just moved to
slide two that would be fantastic
um that's all right
um so to set the context over the course
of 2019 we set off on
a on a journey to develop our traffic
together locality plan which hopefully
will be familiar with a lot of people
um as i know that the health and
well-being board was engaged in
in co-producing uh what i think was a
really um
open and transparent plan and a real set
of system-wide priorities and
aspirations
um and actually what we're saying is
that those absolutely remain
and so the key components of that plan
are still things we want to follow
through with
um what covert has done is maybe change
the ways in which we want to work and
i'll progress onto that in a short while
and some detail on how we think we're
going to do that slightly differently
and again covert has brought so many
things to the forum
and i think it what it has done is
reinforced our
our energy and our commitment around uh
around communities and place-based
solutions
um you move on to the next eye please
thank you
we had a set of i statements which um
and a set of three big key aspirations
which you can see to the left-hand side
of the slide
and the i statements were really all
encompassing and i think it showed the
way in which the
locality plan was developed it wasn't
simply about health services it wasn't
simply about social care studies this
was about general
how do we get the best for people in
trafford how do we ensure that people
are
connected in their communities have good
access to services
i generally happy people um and and
and strive and achieve in life um
and so it wasn't really about those
wider determinants of health
and was at the heart of the farm
you move on to the next slide
what we what we had previously and not
to go into too much detail we had uh
what we referred to as six pillars
and they were six pillars of work which
we thought were the key
components of our health and social care
strategy for the next five years it can
save some of what the nhs was being
asked
in its long-term plan uh plus what we
thought some
of our traffic priorities were along
with some of the greater manchester
asked as well
that come through the partnership and
under the forums and the particular
combined authority
um what we reflected on at the beginning
of this year is that actually
we've been more we we need to be more
fluid we need to understand the
interdependencies of all those
really complex programs of work and they
are really complex
and include everyone in the borough
across all of the different
organizations and sectors to play their
part
in helping us achieve those aspirations
i think
um what kobit has done is it shine a
light on that
and it shone a light in a way that i
think we need to be more transparent
open and inclusive in the way in which
we design
services for the future and how we take
a more asset-based approach to
empowering communities
and the way in which we're trying to do
that is to be
again more open with our partners
involving them from the officer
so that we follow through on that
original commitment to co-production
and so what we're saying is that
actually those those public health
drivers that
base and understanding the demand and
capacity in the system
which we've done amazingly through
through colby to understand the pinch
points in the system and how we need
more capacity in certain places
well actually some of that really good
practice and partnership working with
all our providers
needs to happen moving forward so that
becomes the real core component of how
we plan for the future
um we need to think about the money we
need to think about the amazing impact
that digital has
and actually our workforce our people
are one of the most important things if
not the most important thing in this
in helping us achieve our ambitions and
so it's actually really important that
we have that new way of working where we
think about those enablers as we
previously referred to them
as core components of how we just design
and deliver services in the future and
in some cases those enablers
are the drivers for change um such as
finance being a very obvious example
what i wanted to bring to the attention
of the health and wellbeing
members today and was that sort of that
passage through all the design work
which happens in the system with our
partners in a really inclusive manner
through um through to the right-hand
side of the diagram
which is our trafford local care
alliance again all the strategic
partners sat around the table
um with very good and relationships and
we've seen that throughout kobe i think
if we haven't
built on those relationships over the
pre previous 18 months
then the response here in traffic
throughout it wouldn't have been
um as good and i think it is really a
testament to those relationships and
spending time building those connections
and what we what we feel um the lca is
that it means that
that more formal route through into the
health and well-being board to get that
more rounded view to keep us focused on
prevention
and empowering communities but also then
that linked to
the top of the the sort of um the tree
so to speak
in terms of traffic partnership so
that's the real routine to leave and
support into
addressing those wider determinants of
health can move on to the next slide
thank you and so what what we have
created and it was in a very small
section on that previous slide was the
concept of strategic design groups
and so we we have created four strategic
design groups
uh living well at home which is at the
epicentre of what we want to try and
achieve so
everything that we do has that at its
heart
and we want people to live well in their
community we want um
to have the best set of services and
support available
to make people um get that step closer
to home
in an efficient and safe way with the
right support and
if we have to people to go into hospital
then we want it to be as a short stay as
is possible
uh again so that it really sort of
spins the focus of what we want our
recovery and locality plan to be moving
forward
the strategic design groups are what
they say on the tin
that is about holding um the parameters
for the work within that building
within those groups it is about inviting
in all our partners from the offset
creating the priorities together and
understanding how those priorities
interlink
something that we do in living well at
home will have a direct impact on short
stay in hospital and vice versa
and so we have a program team now that's
wrapped around this there's
uh resource through the council on the
uh the cct and moving forward in the
longer term
and i want to explore how other partners
help us do that
and so that we're all playing our role
in making this happen
and it does feel as though uh that
well there will actually be a series of
other groups and this isn't about
creating an industry and more governance
um as colleagues um originally sort of
chipped in with
but actually now we've had those
conversations and people really do
understand
that we're in a position now where we
want those open conversations
there are four key groups and it is
about corralling the efforts of the
smaller groups which already currently
exist
and so we're not saying that the
locality fund previously has to be
completely rewritten absolutely not this
is about taking the priorities from
there as i said from the outset
and building them into um you know a
structure
but that still allows for those dynamic
conversations we had a really good
conversation at the lca meeting
yesterday about how we just need to pick
up the phone and work with each other
and that's been evident throughout
folding and that needs to be
at the heart of how we continue to work
moving forward next slide please
thank you so i think this is some of the
reflections and i've already touched on
a couple of these points so i won't go
over every single
uh line um but those issues around
uh duplication and interdependence i
think are the really key ones
for us to consider and so how do we have
the right partners at the right time
influencing these conversations and
we've been really
um we've welcomed many conversations
with all our lca partners
and we welcome many more as to how you
play your role in
co-designing what those priorities look
like and then making sure that we have
assurance and bringing those reports
back through into this space so that
everyone is excited on
uh the progress that we are making and
if there are any barriers then how do we
work together to
address those and the last bullet point
i think is a very important one because
this is an
unbelievably fast changing environment
um we've got the asks within the nhs
phase three letter but as it down
alluded to is much broader than that
this is about our priorities as a system
and the phase three and the winter
planning which we would always do
is built in as that so ultimately we
have one plan for traffic that is about
health and social care
recovery and reform and that absolutely
contains all of the information
uh and plans that eleanor has shared in
terms of that ongoing response to covid
as a program team we will try and wrap a
proportion of program management
approach around this
so we're really clear on who's doing
what and by when and this is about
deliverables real tangible things that
will change
um and i want to talk about the world of
public engagement but in making sure
that some of that messaging
gets across from our population in a
very clear and a consistent way
and the work of all of all of this is
supported by a common engagement
steering group
that has a really good link and
complementary set of roles and
responsibilities
to that public engagement board and so
again two both working together there
but one with a very practical ass
with the public engagement board setting
the strategy
and so i think again it's about
utilizing those existing groups that
we've had set up previously not creating
new can move on to the next slide
this is just the team that's wrapped
around this we all have various other
bits of roles uh definitely myself and
what we have now and i think this shows
a commitment to this
is that really cohesive team from the
cctv council working together
to wrap around the support around those
strategic design groups and then through
into
the local care alliance the health and
wellbeing board and traffic partnership
so that this bombs one core component of
the overall traffic recovery plan
for the borough as a whole and so those
are some names and you'll you'll
probably get some noise and we'll
connect with you
and we'll imagine moving forward that
those who we already do
connect with we'll know who we are um
and the rematch of the team is
relatively self-explanatory but down the
right hand side um
and so i don't suppose we go over in
into lots and lots of detail here
people can have these slides and digest
them at their own leisure and the caveat
is that
these are still in draft these are still
being refined on a daily basis
working with the senior responsible
officers and the leads and the chairs
and who are part of these strategic
design groups and
there's a reason why we've got living
well in my community first in this slide
deck and that's because we want that to
be the focus
that on living well at home is what we
want to be here to do
and the other stuff around and making
sure that we have a short stay in
hospital and getting people out of those
uh out of the acute system and back into
their own homes
is absolutely important he's absolutely
pivotal but we want the focus to be on
that so more prevention and asset based
approach that we have
uh here in trafford and build on some of
the good practices that we've got
each of the groups has a set of emerging
priorities they might not be the final
ones but you can start to see
that there are some real tangible things
uh for example
in my community around development of
community hub models
um which i know a lot of people on this
call here are fully involved in
and have been over the last four to five
months and they've been absolutely
amazing
and it's how this group can develop the
strategy moving forward for what they
what they become how they evolve how
they are resourced how do we make them
sustainable
and part of the core infrastructure that
we develop in place
and there's stuff in there around the
recent information information advice
services
and that whole prevention agenda being
worked with them well in my community
but also again um not just here in
health and social care but broader so
making those
linkages and to the other groups that
exist
in other parts of the traffic system
around employment around education
around community collegiate community
safety etc
and so it's about again it's about using
this group to focus in on some very core
priorities but ensuring that the links
are there with other
groups that exist who have got their own
priorities as well and basically
where can we add some value and it might
be an enterprise
capacity um this particular group or it
could be
that actually they're responsible for
for delivering those with the help and
support of partners um
each of these strategic design groups
has an evolving group description which
hopefully says what it does on the team
again we're still in that sort of
consultation co-production phase where
we're testing this with colleagues
and hopefully in the next couple of
weeks and by the time this group meets
next
we'll have a fully fledged set of
documentation which says
these are the priorities this is what
we're responsible for
these are the key individuals and
partners that are part of these
conversations leading the work
and people can be really sort of
up-to-date with the detail for those who
wish to get into some of it
and understand and explore what your
role potentially could be in helping
some of this work
if you just move through to the next
slide
thank you and again you will see there
are there are lots of priorities here in
living well at home
it wouldn't be i think it's one you know
as i said before it's the epicenter of
our efforts i think
um what we need to do and what what sits
behind some of these high-level slides
is a group there's a description of some
of these priorities so
what is it that we're going to do around
medicine management what is it that
we're going to do
around primary care etc and there is a
balance between having business as usual
priorities which we know where our role
is going to be there
safeguarding domestic abuse absolutely
they are
and then differentiate differentiating
sorry between
the transformation and change program so
where are we changing services are
where our service is going to be done
differently because of an impact that
the
impact that kovid has and so again it
goes back to that message about being
very clear with people around what we're
going to do and when
and in the background all the plans are
being developed around what
what these change programs and
priorities look like what they are and
when are they going to happen
um and again there will have to be some
realism with it because
i don't think we can kick off with all
these priorities on the uh on the first
of september for example
um this is about phasing and bringing
things in
um that align with each other and make
sense
and there are some very very clear
priorities that we have to attend to
um in terms of winter and being prepared
and
making sure that we do respond to the
nhs challenges set out within
the phase 3 level
so i think you'll get the idea now the
set of priorities the group description
and it has those estros and senior leads
and so i think in due course i think we
can communicate this out to our wider
partners
in much more detail um in order to have
more
conversations about how you may well
have a role to play
um directly or indirectly in some of
this work you can move on to the next
one
i think that might be the last slide
that goes into some of the detail
okay if you can move on to the next one
please thank you
and so i only very quickly wanted to
touch on communications and engagement
and so just talking before uh as eleanor
alluded to around that common engagement
strategy
having one strategy for the borough and
both having an eye on kovid and what we
do here in terms of
uh engaging with our population where we
need to understand and manage outbreaks
and get proactive messaging out there
but also that bigger piece around
behavior change and how do we build on
some of the excellent behavior change
that we've seen
within the last number of months um that
has happened
um so there is a shot of that that there
is the two-tier ask there in terms of
covid
and then the longer term sort of
five-year low policy health and social
care recovery locality plan
um around proactive campaigns um in the
longer term around
managing weight that's one that's very
much in the media at the moment
and its beneficial impact in terms of uh
tattling forward et cetera et cetera
um there are some key bullet points in
there
on what the asks are that i come out of
our engagement that comes engaging
steering group
around brand development so we can
develop that brand to traffic so people
recognize and buy into
some of the messaging there is some of
the real practical using and utilizing
existing communications channels and
networks um which maybe we've got room
for improvement on
so everyone has networks of their own
both individual networks and more formal
work networks
how do we maximize um those to get
messages out to people
be that covid related or something
completely different
and how do we tie into those um more
important and visual campaigns around
cancer awareness
mental health week et cetera et cetera
so we we have a group there and we've
got some commitments and a written
strategy in its first graph
here and i think we can bring back here
in due course in the next month or so
okay next slide
this was just simply to show and i think
there's a there's a slightly updated
version of
this um this slide since the
conversations we had at the
middle of this week in fact just
yesterday um but it just shows that
the linkages between the working the
local care alliance
and and feeding through into the health
and well being born here for that such
very strategic oversight and the work
becomes an engagement both in the public
engagement board
and the steering group which reports
into the lca
so again you can see the real natural
link between
the different parts of the system there
and the clear responsibilities which are
highlighted
at the bottom of the slide which i've
already alluded to
next slide
and then there was just some things you
just click on
and then marty maywe may wish to come in
at this point
um to just follow up on a couple of
things i wanted to share
but and this was to just generally make
people aware of the phase letter
uh case three letters sorry received
from nhse and
the fact that we now have all the
planning templates and guidance and
although there is a return that is
required by the 1st of september
and that's brought forward to the 24th
because those 10 across greater
manchester have to be
corralled into one version and sent
through uh by the first of september so
we have a really really
um small window in which to collectively
come up with our priorities
and how we're going to respond to the
challenges within the phase three letter
so there are various colleagues in
putting into that it is an absolute
joint process with our partners about
the green trajectories and what's
realistic
and how we're going to achieve some of
those key performance targets
and again i think this is about yes
phase three but it is about
what are our priorities as a system and
actually it's really
it's really comforting to understand
that the work that we've been doing in
developing our health and social care
recovery strategy
addresses nearly every single one of the
challenges set to us
within phase three it's not to say that
very easy absolutely not
um however we have got a handle on what
it is that we think
and we're going to do and how that's
going to make a difference
and again this is about channeling that
effort through the language that we're
using around living well at home
living well in my community and the
other two strategic design groups so
those are the forms in which
will help create the the answers to
phase three and but we
very much see it as that one plan for
health and social care
across trafford which contains the phase
3 asks which contains the winter
response
but also the ambition um to re-look at
what we said in our original
organization
i've probably covered the majority of
this around working in partnership to
make sure that we do this
um so there's probably not anything on
there that i don't think i've uh
i don't think i've covered so you need
some next slide
and i think that might have been it
martin is there anything you
particularly wanted to add to the
uh to the phase three oh there you go
that's our ultimate goal
i've said it a few times um is there
anything martin that you would like to
add to uh just in terms of the phase
three
um thanks tom uh genuinely without being
flippant
what the task feels like in um phase
three has been sent to asda with a very
very
very long shopping list of things that
you need to buy um
but nobody's telling you how much money
you've got because that is the uh
that is the key part of what's missing
at the moment which is what is the
allocation of resources for the second
half of the year
and that's both an nhs issue and a
social
care issue so i'm genuinely not being
flippant about that i just think
you know at times it's best to simplify
things
um so you know we've been told what the
task is
which is fine but we've not been told
what the resource is
thanks martin great point
and anybody have any questions for
i don't know what's happened but my chat
has disappeared now completely
and so i don't know if people are
raising their hands in the bar oh yes i
can see that raised hands in the bar so
and we'll just carry on with that um
council harding do you want to come in
first
uh yeah thanks um good point martin
about the money
and of course we've got the
comprehensive spending review coming up
and i think we need to think very
carefully about what it is
um we're asking for what we need and how
we work as a ccg and local authority
around that
but i guess my question is to tom really
on some of this
um i know i've raised this before at the
health and well-being board
um we talk about co-production a lot
and i'm not sure we do it
great um so i guess i'm asking
how are we genuinely going to co-produce
everything feels really rushed at the
minute you've given a time scale about
how we need to do these things and
obviously it's not your time scale i i'm
just uh it really bothers me that
we've been saying these things for years
the same things and it's much greater
now the impact on our communities are
going to be much greater
my question is how are we going to
genuinely co-produce
some of these work streams how do we
involve the public
we want the public to take greater
responsibility for their health and
well-being
do we involve them at every step but how
we formulate these priorities um
and also i guess just i can see louise
is on the call from the age well board
how how will some of this cascade down
to things like the suicide partnership
board and the age world board
because clearly we will want to lead on
some of the areas of these plans
[Music]
thanks joe um really good questions and
and very good points so i think
coming back on the the issue of
co-production i do think you're right i
think we have
i think we have pockets of really good
co-production but it's not consistent i
think we
we were honest with ourselves when we
wrote the traffic together locality plan
at the back end of last year as to how
we needed to climb up that ladder of
coal production
um that we we used as a visual within
within the strategy
um for me there's a few things one is
that
we do have to push back um against some
of the
what seem impossible time frame
sometimes to to do things
it's a very very fine balance isn't it
between having to
um between responding to
um challenges that we have in our system
and then co-designing them because
actually if we're talking about proper
co-production and doing
a service completely differently and
it's a year in the making we need to be
thinking about these things
in the longer longer term um so there is
something around
taking a more asset based uh approach to
commissioning i think
um in a more structured way that thinks
about one year two year three years in
advance
and in a way this is what we're trying
to do here around the phasing of
priorities so that we can work back from
those dates
um the voice of people um is something
that
the communications and engagement
steering group has actively been
discussing so if you think about the
reach of that particular group
and it has 17 different organizations on
it probably more but 17 regular turn up
a number of colleagues who are on this
call a part of that group we agreed this
week
that we needed and some dedicated effort
and we've got a number of volunteers who
step forward
and to look at insight and intelligence
and how we
not necessarily have to invite people in
to be part of something
but we utilize existing networks and
intelligence and information so each of
those partner organizations
have existing forums with people with
service users etc
and with staff so we we need to not
forget that staff are our people as well
there's a big percentage of our staff in
trafford
uh who who work and live in trafford um
so i think we do need to revisit that
year of engagement that we
originally planned was about engaging
our workforce so i think we need still
need to do that
and and that needs to be brought through
into the strategic design groups for
that to be considered
how we practically do that i think we're
still we still need to work some of that
out
um and we would really welcome any
conversations on on
getting to a point where we know how we
can practically do that without it being
too onerous
um but it is a it's a real balance isn't
it we've just seen that you know
the responses to get things in by next
week and things like that
and just simply don't allow the time for
that so we have to push back sometimes
when we've got the ability to do so
and we've got to utilize those existing
networks and all our partnerships
and the reaches into their networks to
bring that intelligence back into shape
services
and and we have to work on what's next
for commissioning
um how do we take that more asset based
approach um
which in which actually starts to think
about that commissioning cycle a little
bit more differently i think
and then maybe previously we have done
but we build from the good practice and
not to say that we don't always do that
there's some great you know evidence of
doing co-production here in trafford
but it's just not consistent across
everything that we do so we just got to
build on that best practice
you uh councillor brophy do you have a
question
yeah so thank you for the report and i
think the
comment at the end really sums it up
it's a very ambitious report clearly and
congratulations on that but it
it does seem that within the time scales
and the resources
my concern is the people that might fall
through the gaps and open my
professional work in the nhs and just
being part of the community
there are some groups that aren't
actually accessing services so we know
that everybody who's got
any kind of mental health condition or
anything existing
it's potentially got worse within the
lockdown and isolation situation that
we've all faced
there's some people who are still
shielding and not wanting to come out
quite frightened by the virus my concern
is
are we sure that we've actually got hold
of all the groups that might be needing
services so there's the obviously the
obvious people like the people shielding
or long-term conditions
already on a list somewhere of having
health needs
are we sure we've identified all the
people within our community might have
health needs
that might need support in some way
that's my question
i think it's a very good question others
may want to chip in on this after
i've i've been able to just respond
quickly um
i think it is a huge challenge isn't it
um we know who we know
um and even even then i think um we've
got that many lists of lists
uh whereby we have information on
individuals
how we share that information i think
again is something that's developing in
the background and i know it was a
priority across greater manchester
evolution to break down some of those
barriers around
information sharing so that that
information then becomes intelligence
um and and i think that that has to
remain a priority moving forward
and i think and just giving it quite a
practical example of how
i think we can make a difference and
reach those people who would not maybe
reach before
and so that they don't get to that
tipping point of using services on a
consistent basis and falling into
falling into into that routine and so we
can get in with that prevention early
intervention
for me is around how we're trying to
empower
the vcsc sector and work with them to
create a collective
more of an engagement and a key role in
leading the work particularly in that
living well in my community strategic
design group
that i alluded to previously because
actually they have the intelligence all
those networks and the
unbelievable work that happened and that
is still happening through the community
hubs
has been driven by those organizations
because they know people that
we as statutory organizations might not
um because you know your neighbours you
know your streets
and it's part of that i think that more
good citizen approach that we need to
build into
um the plan moving forward so i think
there is a key role to empower
and someway support financial and
otherwise
um the vcsc sector to be that reach into
communities whereby we probably don't
have them at the moment
which again you go it was actually if
you to get back to the presentation
the the bottom of the four priorities
that weren't in any order but that was
around
having that more sort of cohesive vcsc
sector
um collected and infrastructure in place
moving forward so i think we've realized
that
what kovid has taught us is that if we
empower that sector the intelligence
rich intelligence that we can get
complements the information we have
available to us and that i think then
starts to some way
go to address some of those people who
we might not reach who we actually were
just about to stop from falling into
um services
um heather do you want to come in
uh yeah thanks um a few points
um i think the um the first one is
on the uh document pack 16 where we've
got
under the covered public engagement
board
the longer term strategy for health and
social care reform
uh i heard what um was said about that
by tom
but i do think that that doesn't sit
very comfortably
particularly uh in that group
it's a much much bigger uh issue
unless it's specifically around covid
so i think either needs to be reworded
or put somewhere else
and in terms of page
13 in the document pack
i think firstly um i would like to see
that some of the
um strategies that are mentioned here
are fed back into the health and
wellbeing board
specifically the mental health strategy
which healthwatch has never seen
and also the learning disability and
strategy as well
and again we've not seen that and
i think that we also need to look at uh
apart from the feedback to the health
and wellbeing board i think that we need
to be quite clear
somewhere about the role of public
consultation in some of the changes that
are taking place
and and that has never been articulated
so we need to be clear about that
and we also need to be clear about where
we want
equality and impact assessments
uh as well so those are things that i
would want to see added
finally um in terms of the um
phase three priorities again i've not
seen anything on that
and uh i've would value seeing those
because clearly we would like some input
into what those priorities should be
and i accept that there are short time
scales
but short time scales cannot overcome
all of the other issues that have been
raised by
the members today uh about transparency
and about the ability to
um participate and put forward
views and opinions um
and i think that's it thanks
thanks heather um am i okay uh just
coming back on a couple of points there
yeah
um so just to pick up the point around
the mental health strategy so in our
forward plan
um we are aiming to have a first
draft of the mental health strategy
going back to the october local care
alliance
um so again that can absolutely come
come here and welcome here
given the sort of the reporting
arrangements from the lca into this
board
um and again um the
the issue around public consultation and
i think is a really important one
probably one and again heather you're
you're part of the group aren't you part
of the commons engagement steering group
one probably we've not touched upon um
but absolutely in the background it is
part
of the planning so as part of the
strategic design groups whenever we're
thinking about reforming and
transforming or stopping or doing things
completely different
um with any health and social care
services
then if there is a requirement to
consult and engage then we absolutely
will do
and and that goes back to my point
around seeing those enablers not as an
add-on so we think about it as something
at the end so we transform the service
then we've got lying on a minute
we've got to communicate this in some
way it's about bringing that to the
beginning of the conversation and saying
how to embed comms and engagement from
the offset
in these things we are potentially going
to change um
and so that's the sort the switch and i
think the difference in terms of maybe
how we were thinking previously
and how we were thinking moving forward
but i think we've all got a role to
play in that and both the public
engagement board and uh from covered
perspective but particularly the commons
engagement student group has a very
important role there to play
um in terms of phase three lester i'm
sure that we we can circulate the one
that's
um that's been relatively far and wide
and so i'm sure we can circulate that
afterwards to colleagues so that people
can get an understanding of
what the the overarching asks are um
i'm sure we can get that out after this
meeting okay just
uh briefly coming back and again
building up on an earlier point about
co-production
um i have seen nothing around any of the
two strategies that i mentioned
and we would certainly have some strong
views about what we would want to see
going into both a mental health and a
learning disability strategy
so you know this has been an ongoing
issue for a long
time and i've raised it several times
and i think it would regrettable if
something comes
into a group without us having had a an
opportunity
to look at it and to be able to
influence it
yeah so again just coming back on that i
had this so the mental health
transformation group which was on the um
on one of the very early slides that i
put up which showed how the sort of
system connects
and there's a mental health
transformation group and i think that
just met for the first time last week
and just to try and literally get
everyone in the same room so i think
the intention is that that work will
will start now and everyone will be
involved
yeah but why why haven't i why have i
not and healthwatch not been involved is
the point
if you've already had a meeting why is
healthwatch not been involved
so i think that was just the main
partners to come together to have an
exploratory conversation it wasn't to
discuss the strategy in any detail
that that conversation as you've already
alluded to needs to happen with everyone
else
and it will do in your course
do you want to come in around those
issues now
uh i just wanted to um take heather's
point in that heather
diane and i met with healthwatch and we
met with andrew and we had some
um conversations about some of the key
pieces of work that we
had agreed together that healthwatch
will be involved in
and then along came covid so i just want
you to be assured that absolutely
we commission healthwatch and we want to
work together because you
are um our eyes and ears if you like
with members of the public and patients
and i can say hand on heart that i want
to make sure that we are accessible and
transparent and you know my views on
mental health so i completely support
um the words that you say so just to say
that we will
pick up this conversation outside of
this meeting because absolutely
and i know that there is lots of work
and i myself have also
lobbied and rallied for a mental health
strategy so to support some of the
things that you're saying but
we will pick up with you outside of this
meeting and i'll drop you an email
thanks john thanks
joe and derek did you want to come in
yeah i just wanted to pick up on um some
of the points that um
tom was making round about about vcse
engagement the vcse collected
um and i just want to say you know one
of the things that i'm pleased about
is that the statutory services for us as
a vcsc sector
it's been a little bit frustrating in
the past dealing with yourselves
because the wheels take a long time to
actually get anything done but as a
result of covid
we've actually proved that you the
sector can respond
and work differently really really
quickly and i really hope that that will
that will continue because it has been a
massive
massive massive impact to us at the bcec
sector
however what i will say is
organizations in the vcsc sector are
also responding quickly
to covid we have been impacted
financially because of our funding
structures
so particularly where we deliver where
we have been delivering services
particularly to people with long-term
health conditions
those are the people who are now
isolating
and it's very difficult to provide some
of the services that we did before
and to be funded in the same way so the
point i'm making is
talking about people who are falling
through the gaps there are still people
out there
who are perhaps not receiving the direct
support that they would need because
organizations within the vcse center
don't have the money to support them
we are um as the vcsc sector
are really working really really hard
to pick up some of the covid uh recovery
monies but that in itself is very very
challenging
because it's highly competitive and
there's no guarantee that
um that we can do that so my worry
is that as time progresses if we do not
get um the appropriate level of support
some organizations that are providing
some really good work
in the sector will no longer be here um
once covid has passed or once we were i
know covid is still with us
but as we work through cobia there is a
real real
risk of some organizations that are
providing really good services
of not being around
uh and they are extremely um
they are high up on the list if not the
highest on the list but in my in my eyes
not not just in from a living well in my
community perspective as a strategic
design group but i think
the system as a whole i think it's
recognized the import and the impact
that
the sector has had over this last number
of months and we do need to think about
seriously that growth strategy
and how we think about local wealth
building to get
people on a more sustainable footing
moving forward so really good points
thanks tom and i've got um hands
hands from diana and elena so we'll take
and diane first and then we'll take
helena and then we'll move on to the
next item thank you
thank you jane and chad just
going back to really to counselor both
these questions around um
reaching everybody i think it's a really
important point just to remind people
that we obviously
have thousands of people that were
shielding that were being phoned and
checked upon and supplied with
food and support as the shielding has
ended
we have a list of people that we are
maintaining contact with
the cab hotline is still open and
available and will continue
for anyone to ring to seek support and
we are using the primary care messaging
system
to all of our residents to get messages
out to people to make sure they know
about those access points
we cannot possibly know everybody and
everything but
those mechanisms are in place and we'll
continue to make sure we reach as many
people as possible
that need support
thanks diane um ellen do you do you want
to come in and we'll
move on to the next item after you
thanks yeah no it's just really to say
um
the role of the health and well-being
board in making sure that the lca plans
happen
is i think absolutely critical because
we are the group
that can make them happen we are here
because we have
you know we're all we and absolutely not
dismissing any of the funding issues
that people have it's absolutely real
and it's across
every part of the organization and covid
has made a lot of situations that were
already difficult
much worse and it's meant that some
office and then things are
more expensive to deliver etc but as a
group we are the people who should be
able to unblock things for trafford
and really i suppose what i'm not
perhaps for this meeting but for
reflection on and bringing back because
what we need to be doing i think
is looking at that work plan which is
fabulous and it absolutely needs that
public engagement and we will not make
the difference to our population's
health without that public engagement
we don't have the health stats that we
should have in trafford
given the demographics in trafford when
we're underperforming
so we've got savings to make if we can
actually improve our population health
through the prevention work through
everything else through that bcsc
and uh community engagement but i think
fundamentally we have to be saying
we're holding ourselves to account for
saying if we want to do this
we have to be clear that we're doing it
and if we're not doing it
we should be say understanding why we
haven't done it and why we're doing
something else in instead so i'm really
hoping for the next meeting we can bring
back some of these things both from the
10 point action plan
and for the um for the lca plans that
tom's
um outlined and say okay well we said
this was the things we're doing let's
celebrate the ones that we're on with
and
we're doing really well on and let's
understand why we're not achieving some
of the others so that we can make sure
that we use this tone to best defect and
that we can use
our own powers to then unblock the
things that haven't worked so it's a bit
of a
rallying call to seize the power
that we should have thank you
thank you eleanor um
let's i'm just mindful of the time if we
can move on to
now onto item 10 it's then our infection
control annual report
and it's over to you again anna thank
you so much
this is um this is the report of our
community infection control team
who it's a very small team we've got um
three nurses
and some admin support and it's sorry
and in fact there is one of our nurses
ringing me at this
very moment um
but uh the so it's really to summarize
the work that they've done all year
um obviously this year they've spent an
awful lot of time on the coveted work
but i do feel that a lot of the success
we've had in the care homes have been
down to the work obviously of diane's
team of care homes themselves
and of our community infection control
team with the support that they have
given to those teams
both in reducing the risk of outbreaks
and in managing outbreaks
but it's also just to show all the other
pieces of work that they do because
the covid is not the only infectious
disease out there
and they have been working tirelessly on
reducing the risks for
diarrhea and vomiting from
c difficile and mrsa and all the other
infectious diseases that people get in
the borough
so any questions but it's just um you
know
fantastic piece of you know fantastic
team really good engagement really
grateful
to them for the work that they do
particularly with our care homes and
also with our gp practices
and the support that they get and advice
that they are able to give to our gps
so any questions
um there's no hands raised eleanor and
there's nothing
in chat so everybody must be thinking
it's marvelous
i hope so thank you very much
and there are no other items on the
agenda
so i'd just like to thank everybody for
attending today
thank you for everybody's contribution
thank you for being patient with me
because somehow i managed to log myself
out
so thank you very much everybody and and
see you see you next time thanks thanks
very much
bye
you